This video is made possible by brilliant.
You're going to learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you would like to learn more about the right now,
got a brilliant.org forward slash biographics who will also find a link in the
description below.
Okay.
He is known as one of the most intelligent men to have walked the earth,
yet his private life was nothing short of chaotic.
He was the world's most celebrated scientist,
yet he shuns the limelight.
He ushered in the atomic age,
but he was a lifelong pacifist.
In this week's biographics,
we delve into the contradictory life of Albert Einstein.
Herman ends,
Pauline Einstein,
a Jewish couple,
married three years earlier,
welcomed their first child.
Albert's on March the 14th 1879 six weeks after his birth.
They moved from Ulm,
Germany to Munich as a result of failed business endeavors in Munich,
palm and joined forces with his brother and an electrical engineering business,
which was propped up by Pauline's parents.
Three years later,
they had their second child,
Maria,
with the influence of his musically talented mother.
Albert started musical studies at the age of five learning the piano is than the
violin.
Einstein developed an appreciation for music at an early age and Lisa roads.
If I were not a physicist,
I would probably be a musician.
I often think in music.
I live my daydreams in music.
I see my life in terms of music.
I get most joy in my life out of music.
He was enrolled in a Catholic school in 1885 switching over to the more advanced
Luitpold gymnasium in 1888 which is now known as the Albert Einstein Gen
nauseum.
He proved to be an adequate,
but by no means outstanding students.
By 1894 the electrical manufacturing business that Albert's father and uncle ran
was facing serious difficulty.
For the last decade there had been making DC current componentry,
but now ac current was gaining ascendancy and demand for their services as it
dried up with no income coming in home and decided to move the family to Italy
where job prospects looked a bit brighter.
However,
15 year old Albert,
he stayed behind to complete his schooling in Munich.
Albert did not enjoy your schooling and often butted head with the strict route
teachers.
He chafed at the strict discipline and the lack of freedom for any creative
thought.
The subjects that were taught to him,
they just held no interest for him except that was for mathematics.
He has a natural affinity for the subject and it's quickly mastered any work
that was presented to him.
From around the age of 12 I began teaching himself advanced mathematical
concept,
starting with Algebra.
His father engaged to tutor Max Talmud Ms. Soon Malbec was out thinking even him
tell him it's presented the boy with a geometry textbook.
He later commented.
Einstein had worked through the whole book.
He thereupon devoted himself to higher mathematics.
Soon the flight of his mathematical genius was so high I could not follow
Einstein's dotted teaching in self calculus at age 12 and as a 14 year old,
he says that he had mastered integral and differential calculus.
Soon off to his family's moved to SLE,
Einstein forge a doctor's note,
which convinced the principal of the new pole gymnasium to allow him to quit
school and join his family in Italy.
He still had a year to go before completing is required schooling and it has
empty sky out of attending his last year of high school,
I took an entrance exam and the Swiss Federal Polytechnic University in Zurich.
He came out with excellent results in maths and physics,
but fails in every other subjects.
This school's in physics and math,
sweat,
so outstanding that they call it the eye of the school's principal.
He encouraged the family to sends Alba to the counties and school in Arou
Switzerland's in order to do increases knowledge.
It was arranged with the 17 year old just stay with the family of a professor of
the school,
Yoast villa during his year with the villas.
Elliot fell in love with Vince Ella's daughter,
17 year olds,
Marie Evans,
a that they had a brief foray.
Man Switch came to an end when Marie moved to Oseberg jump Starter Teaching
Korea
having found his academic passion.
Now there's applied himself to his studies in Switzerland.
He passed the Swiss material with outstanding grades in physics and mathematics
and then reapplied to the Swiss Polytechnic University in Zurich.
This time he passed and was admitted into a four year physics and mathematics
teaching diploma program.
It was around this time that Albert also renounced his German citizenship in
order to avoid compulsory military training that would face him in a few months.
When he turned 18 Albert soon became friends with the only girl in his class,
Mileva marriage.
They both shared a love for science.
Being at the top of that class mean I spent a semester in Heidelberg,
Germany.
When she was away,
she and Einstein wrote to each other almost every day.
Once she returns their friendship at turned into a relationship.
Einstein's parents,
they oppose the union due to the difference in religion,
culture,
and age.
As the couple's relationship flourished.
Money that started to struggle with our studies in 1900 buying Stein pass the
final exam,
but Malave have failed afterwards.
She works at raising her knowledge so that she could retake the test.
It was around this time that she founds out,
but she was pregnant.
My mother decided to move in with their parents in early 19 oh zero she gave
birth to their daughter and I sell.
No one is sure what happened to my labor and Alvin's daughter with many thinking
that she was either adopted or died of scarlet fever.
I would struggle to find a teaching position following his graduation.
This was partly due to the fact that he had alienated many of his teachers over
the four years of his studies.
He gave off the impression that they had.
There's a lot of value to impart to him and he preferred to do his own
independent study.
He finally secured a job,
but it was one that was totally unrelated to his course of study and four by his
contemporaries to be below him.
Having gained his Swiss citizenship,
he became eligible to work for the Swiss government.
He secured a position working as a clerk and the Swiss Patent Office for
intellectual property.
Einstein's job was to assess patterns,
applications for all manner of devices.
Quite a number of the patent applications involved the transmission of
electrical signals and the electromechanical synchronization of time.
These concepts jelled with Einstein's area of personal fascination and served as
the impetus for his investigations,
exploring the nature of light and the relationship between space and time.
While his days were filled with patents applications,
Einstein spent his evenings working on his scientific theories.
He started a discussion group with a few friends.
Conrad Holbeck ends Maury solid vine.
He called this group the Olympia Academy Albert's Mla,
but they reunited in 1903 and they got married that same year.
The couple of wins on to have two sons Han's born in 1904 and Eduardo,
who arrived in 1910
1905 it was a turning point for appetite and Stein.
Over the last couple of years,
he had been building our reputation as an up and coming intellect among the
scientific community.
In April of 1905 he completed his thesis in association with a professor of
experimental physics by the name of Alfred Kleiner.
Einstein received a phd from Zurich University.
Shortly thereafter,
during the second half of 1905 Albert produced for scientific papers.
The subjects of his dissertations were photo electric effect Brownie in motion,
special relativity and the equivalents of mass and energy.
Each of them was received and things he Astley by the intelligentsia.
However,
it was the fourth paper that gave the world its most famous equation.
E stands for energy,
m stands for mass and c squared for the speed of light multiplied by itself.
What it meant in practical terms was that mass could be changed into energy and
vice versa.
As a result,
tiny packets of mass could be converted into huge bursts of energy.
The 26 year old Einstein halves with the publication of his paper on the
equivalency of mass and energy,
it ushered in the atomic age.
Among those who heaped praise upon Einstein for his work was one of the most
preeminent quantum theorists of the day,
and that was max Planck from Germany.
His backing gave Albert instant credibility.
He began receiving speaking requests from all over Switzerland's along with
offers of teaching positions is day is at the patent office while they were
certainly over.
So this is a biography channel and we're not diving into the depths of
Einstein's work today,
but if you'd like to really get an understanding of just what he works on,
you should absolutely check out today's sponsor.
Brilliance.
Brilliance are science learning platform that allow you to learn through
something called active learning.
Basically to sum this up,
this is kind of the opposite of that feeling of reading a complex paragraph
about some principle and then just having no idea what's going on and then you
probably read it again and he was still don't have any idea what's going on.
Probably not just me.
It's kind of just that inability to absorb complex information.
It's totally normal.
It's also totally not the best way to learn.
Brilliant.
Take even something like special relativity and make it easy to understand.
They give you something super short to read and then you immediately apply that
to a problem and just a rinse and repeat and suddenly are understanding all
sorts of crazy stuff that you didn't think you'd ever understands.
I've used brilliant and I think you should just go and try it out to see how
fascinating it is that you can learn a complex subject so quickly and easily.
It's just remarkable how quickly you can grasp something,
whether you want to learn about paradoxes in space,
time in that place in special relativity.
Useful for today's video or maybe something completely different like advanced
stats.
Well,
brilliant is why you should do it.
Support biographics by going to brilliant.org forward slash biographics and
let's get back to Einstein,
shall we?
Einstein worked the lecture circuit and then took up a position as a lecturer at
the University of Bern in 1908 during that year,
he also returned to his Alma Mater,
the University of Zurich.
The university authorities was like taken with the budding genius that they
created a position just for him as an associate professor in the theoretical
physics departments.
He transferred there from Burn University in 1909 two years later.
Einstein gains a full professorship when he took up the position that the
Charles Virgin and university in Prague to take up the position he had to take
out Australian citizenship,
but as he would only remain in the position for 12 months.
Over that time,
he published a total of 11 scientific papers.
Then in 1912 he returned to the University of Zurich where he took,
I'll pay full professorship and the theoretical physics department.
He was able to work alongside his longtime friend and collaborator,
Marcel Grossmann,
as well as teaching the laws of thermodynamics and also lectured on analytical
mechanics.
That's in year.
Einstein began an extra marital affair with his first cousin,
said love,
and Tal Einstein was not really there much for his family all of his time and
energy into his work and research.
For several years,
he had been emotionally distant from his wife.
Recently letters were found that he wrote in 1910 to his first love Marie Vinzel
lab in them,
he professed his undying love for her and lamented the life that they had missed
out on together
in 1914 Einstein,
I breach it his family yet again,
and it took up a position at the Kaiser Wilhelm Institute for Physics located at
the University of Berlin.
He would remain in Germany for the next 19 years and we're soon appointed
director of the institute.
The position gave him professorship without teaching duties,
which afforded him time to work on his scientific studies and other major draw
for the return to Germany was that it allowed him to be closer to his mistress
[inaudible] towards the end of 1914 believe that moved back to Zurich with her
sons.
After finding out about her husband's affair,
it's coming to the realization that Albert was not capable of being a family
man.
Einstein divorcement over in April of 1919 then in June,
he married his cousin in 1960 and Einstein published his theory of general
relativity.
This was a groundbreaking achievement in the world of physics.
It's theorized that what we see as the force of gravity actually results from
the curvature of space and time.
As a result,
the earth is not actually being pulled towards the sun by gravity,
but rather by the interaction of space and time,
which dictates how LVF moves.
Einstein predicted that lights from another star would be Ben spine,
the sun's gravity during a solar eclipse in 1919 that prediction,
it was confirmed the publicity that surrounded the confirmation of this theory
is went around the globe and for the first time the name Albert Einstein,
it became internationally known.
Yeah,
and the only 1920s Einstein became a celebrity among the scientific community in
America.
He was invited to New York,
so kick off a three week lecture tour in April of 1921 he lectured at Columbia
and Princeton among other places of learning.
He also managed to get in and they tore off the White House.
Einstein's first impression of America was the positive one.
Shortly after his return,
he published an essay called my first impressions of America and dinettes.
He wrote what strikes a visitor is the joyous,
positive attitude to life.
The American is friendly,
self confidence,
optimistic and without envy.
In 1921 Einstein's popularity,
it reached a new high when he was awarded the Nobel Prize for physics because
there's theories on general and special relativity were not yet widely accepted.
This award was given for his explanation of the photo electric effect throughout
the 1920s Albertson Nelson and undertook a number of international tours that
saw them being received in such far flung places as Singapore or Japan in
Palestine and December of 1930 he made a second trip to the United States.
This time he wanted to fly under the radar feeling that he had received a far
too much attention on his first visit.
That's tries.
He me,
he still found himself being overwhelmed with offers to speak and invitations to
receive awards.
All of them.
He turned down.
However,
when he tried to slip into New York City,
he couldn't avoid the celebrity of being awarded the keys to the city by Mayor
Jim Walker.
When he visited the New York Riverside Church.
He was surprised to find that the congregants that created a life size statue of
him.
He then moved on to California where he was introduced to a number of movie
stars and Pleading Charlie Chaplin.
These two men,
the actually remained lifelong friends.
On one occasion,
chaplain and Einstein appeared together in public to great applause at that
binds Einstein turn to chaplain and said,
they are sharing us both to this chaplain replied,
they're applauding you because none of them understands you and applauding me
because everybody understands me.
Back in Germany,
things were beginning to look rather ominous.
With the rise of the Nazi party,
the rights of Jews,
they rapidly diminished.
They were no longer permitted to hold positions of authority,
so Einstein was removed from his directorship of the Kaiser Wilhelm Institute.
Despite being the most famous scientist on the planet,
he couldn't even teach in the local secondary school while he was on his
overseas tours is home,
was raided by the Gestapo.
In February,
1933 Einstein was on another tour of the United States with Elsa.
Without off Hitler having been proclaimed chancellor of Germany just a few weeks
earlier.
Albert's knew that there was no future for him and the country of his birth,
the couple of sale to Belgium and March.
Upon arrival in Antwerp,
Einstein went directly to the German consulate and renounced his German
citizenship than Nazis.
Later sold his boat and converted his cottage into a Hitler youth camp.
The Einstein's rented a house in Dawn,
Belgium for a couple of months.
During that time,
news of the Nazi book burnings reached them.
It was reported that all of our butts writings had been consumed in the flames.
A German magazine published the list of enemies of the state and it included
Einstein alongside his name was the caption,
not yet hang,
offering a $5,000 bounty on his head.
In July of 1933 nine stone was invited to London for six weeks at the request of
an old British naval officer friends.
While there he had an audience with Winston Churchill,
he asked for British assistance to bring as many Jewish scientists sounds of
Germany as possible.
Giotto was immediately receptive.
Over the coming is Einstein used his influence to arrange for placements of more
than a thousand scientists and teaching positions at universities outside of
Germany on his returns and Belgium.
Einstein was offered a resident's scholarship at Princeton University in October
of 1933 he ends,
Elsa sailed again for the United States.
Einstein took up the position to Princeton University and the Institute for
Advanced Study in 1935 he was granted permanent residency in America.
He got his US citizenship in 1940 and 1935 and new tribulation arose.
Feinstein,
his wife Elsa,
was diagnosed with heart and kidney problems.
The following.
Yeah,
sadly she died.
This was to be his biggest trial yet it's now.
Einstein was not one to show his emotions,
but it was said by a friend's pita Bucky that he shed a tear off dialysis
passing.
This might not sound like much,
but throughout that whole friendship he had never once seen outlet to cry.
In 1939 a couple of young Hungarian scientist named Leo Szilard and Eugene Vigna
discovered the science behind the atomic bomb.
They tried to informing those in positions of power,
but they had no influence,
so they were just ignored.
Then they decided to reach out to someone who would have credibility with those
in high power.
That's we spend,
they contacted Albert Einstein,
said Landon Vigna explained their theory to Einstein and he was quick to
understand the concepts,
so wrote a letter to President Roosevelt with Einstein signature on it.
The letter urged America to create the first atomic bomb before Germany did.
It is generally agreed that the addition of Einstein's signature was a key
influencer and President Roosevelt's adoption of the atomic bomb development
projects that was known as the Manhattan project.
The u s government launched a Manhattan project in December of 1941 amazingly,
Einstein's application to be a part of the project was turned down.
The reason for this was simply that he was a German and people were worried that
he might be a spy for the Nazis.
On August the sixth and August the ninth 1945 the atomic bomb was used on the
Japanese cities,
Hiroshima and Nagasaki killing at least 129,000 people.
Five months prior to his death.
Abbott said that his greatest mistake in life with signing that letter to
President Roosevelt concerning the atomic bomb,
he stated I made one great mistake in my life when I signed the letter to
President Roosevelt recommending that atom bombs be made,
but there was some justification,
the danger that the Germans would make them.
Einstein was never comfortable about his fame.
He once said in the past,
it never occurred to me that every casual remark of mine would be snatched up
and record it otherwise I would have crept further into my shell by the time
that he was settled into his life in America.
However,
he realized that he was able to use this celebrity status as a vehicle toward
promoting important causes.
Einstein had been a lifelong pacifist and humanitarian.
Now he used his platform to bring these causes to the fall.
During the 1940 [inaudible] gave his support to the cause of civil rights in the
United States.
He considered racism to be the worst disease in America.
He joins the National Association for the advancement of colored people and a CP
and it became friendly with civil rights activists to w E.
B.
Du Bois.
When du Bois was arrested in 1951 Einstein's offered to be a character witness
was enough to get the case dismissed.
In 1946 he was awarded an honorary degree from Lincoln University in
Pennsylvania,
which was the first in America to award degrees to black students.
He sold that racism in America was handed down from one generation to the next.
Einstein also spoke out against antisemitism.
He developed a friendship with the first prime minister of the new state of
Israel,
David,
Ben Gurion,
regarding prejudice against Jews in various parts of the world.
He said there are no German Jews.
There are no Russian Jews.
There are no American Jews.
There are in fact only Jews.
He did not believe in a personal God who concerns himself with the actions of
humans.
He did say,
however,
that I am not an atheist preferring to call himself an agnostic when boss,
if he believed in an afterlife.
Einstein quips.
No one life is enough for me and that life,
it would end on the 17th of April,
1955 at the age of 76 he had been suffering from internal bleeding caused by the
rupture of an abdominal aortic aneurysm,
which should previously been reinforced surgically.
The night before his passing at Princeton Hospital when offered surgery,
Einstein said,
I want to go when I,
once it is tasteless to prolong life artificially.
I've done my share.
It is time to go.
I will do it elegantly.
In a memorial lecture in 1965 nuclear physicist Jay Robert Oppenheimer
summarized his impression of Einstein as such,
he was almost wholly without sophistication and wholly without wealthiness.
There was always with him a wonderful purity at once.
Childlike,
and it's profoundly stubborn is I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and do not forget to subscribe.
Say,
please do check out our sponsor.
Brilliant.
You'll find a link to them below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.